You know,
there are other ways to predict
what your users will want to type.
>> Yeah, for instance, if you already
have your users relevant data,
why not just prefill the form for them?
It's easy enough.
>> Even if your users aren't logged in,
you can still help them out.
For example, you could guess their
location using location services.
Check the instructor notes for
more details.
In the end, this is all in the pursuit
of the most important principles to take
out from this lesson.
Speed equals conversions.
>> This lesson got you thinking
about fast, efficient inputs, but
you are just getting started.
In the next lesson, you'll dive
into other time-saving tricks,
like creating inputs that
support autofill and validation.
>> Awesome, see you there.